happy Thursday everyone how we doing
I'm Tom shallowing in for Greg Gutfeld
who said he had to attend something deep
in the woods off Interstate 95.
I'm not sure what it was but it sounded
urgent anyway don't pretend you're not
glad to see me
it's almost 2023 which means two things
one I'll be old enough to rent a car
and two Joe Biden will be halfway
through his presidency
[Applause]
apps like Joe falling off a bicycle
let's talk about how he's finishing
2022. on Wednesday President Biden
welcomed Ukrainian leader zielinski to
the White House assuring him U.S support
in the fight against Russia zielinski
gave Biden a Ukrainian cross for
military Merit which Biden called
undeserved but much appreciated which I
think is the same thing Joe said after
he got elected
thank you
[Laughter]
but that might have been the most normal
moment the administration's had in the
past week take for instance the second
quarter jobs report they claimed the U.S
added more than one million jobs between
March and June and that's not including
the 140 replacements for Kamala staffers
at the Federal Reserve Bank of
Philadelphia report released last week
said job growth was essentially flat
that only 10 500 jobs were added during
that time and since it's the Federal
Reserve Bank of Philadelphia the report
concluded with the sound of gunfire
so again it's Biden trying to take
credit for economic achievements that
simply aren't there but hey maybe we
just used to a befuddled president at
this point on Friday during a town hall
on Veterans Benefits he casually said
some weird things about being Irish
while botching his wife's family history
I may be Irish but I'm not stupid
I married Dominic giaco's daughter so
you know I got a little Italian to me
now you know
it makes sense
according to a basic understanding of
biology
[Laughter]
and he got his wife's genealogy wrong
Dominic chicopa was Jill Biden's
grandfather not her father
no biggie I guess you say tomato I say
you're senile
laughs
and as for the Irish they are very smart
all right when they're not drinking
which is at least one day a week
but that wasn't even Joe's most
interesting moment from that event
moments later Joe told this tale of his
Uncle Frank Biden winning the Purple
Heart for his actions in World War II
you know I uh my dad when I got elected
vice president he said Joey
Uncle Frank fought in the Battle of the
Bulge she was not feeling very well now
not because the Battle of balds but he
said and he won the Purple Heart
and you never received it you never he
never got it do you think you could help
him get it or surprise him
so he got on the Purple Heart
it's a touching story but maybe not
accurate
true his Uncle Frank Biden served in the
army during World War II but he died in
1999 and Biden's father Joe senior died
in 2002 when Joe was still in the Senate
he didn't become VP until 2009 so at the
very least his timeline's a little off
but multiple outlets and researchers
from the New York Post couldn't locate
any reference to Frank Biden receiving
the Purple Heart while he was alive or
posthumously which as you know means at
the post office
[Laughter]
the Army notes that there's not a
consistent record of Purple Heart
recipients yeah you know who'd want to
keep a list of such a meaningless thing
like that right
but neither Frank's Tombstone nor his
obituary identify him as a purple heart
honoree so the details of Joe's story
like his second quarter job numbers
don't add up
and the idea of Frank receiving a Purple
Heart isn't an ish isn't the issue
really it's another case of Biden
embellishing a story that's suspect at
this point I no longer believe believe
that Joe earned his own Purple Heart
from the war of 1812.
it's a pattern that's become more common
than Julie Banderas saying why yes I
will have that six glass of Pinot
cabernetes I cut the wine wrong
so what's in store for Joe in 2023 well
maybe more friction between him and his
VP according to a new Politico report
and a book out in January it claims that
Biden called Kamala Harris a work in
progress last year
which is kind of like calling a plane
crash an unexpected layover
apparently Joe vented to a friend that
he was frustrated that Kamala was always
complaining about the jobs that were
assigned to her that included deterring
illegal immigration and pushing Congress
to pass an election reform and voting
rights law according to the book which I
don't intend to read
Biden was annoyed he hadn't asked Harris
to do anything he hadn't done as vice
president and she'd begged him for the
voting rights assignment and like
everything else Kamala gets put in
charge of that voting initiative flopped
so anything to add Joe
no no no
yeah I like Camilla she's all right
I like her almost as much as that
zaletsky guy
oh I like zaletski with the uh I like
having those little
tight t-shirts he looks good he looks
like a little GI Joe
yeah we ought to sell those little uh
little GI Joe kind of zaletskis with the
Kung Fu grip
holding onto a nice fat wad of American
Cash
[Applause]
Wayne she's out sick she always brings a
note from her mixologists Fox News
anchor and author of the children's book
Fiona's Fantastical for it Bottoms Up
Julie Banderas
[Applause]
his writing appears in America's top
magazines newspapers and Ransom notes
Fox News contributor in Washington Times
opinion editor Charlie hurts
thank you
Jay's got stronger columns than the
Parthenon
editor-in-chief of the Federalist Molly
Hemingway
and he's the man of a thousand faces all
of them terrified
writer and comedian Joe Mackey
[Applause]
so Charlie what are your thoughts on
zelenski's visit
wow
um you know
you know I have uh you know I'm I'm just
an American citizen I have uh you know
one member of Congress uh two senators
this is a guy that's got bartenders yeah
yeah this is a guy that has uh what 400
uh congressmen and 97 Senators
um it's extraordinary we've never seen
anything like it um the guy just comes
over it's you know we've become his ATM
machine as everybody's pointed out uh he
comes you know dressed like a perfect
description dressed like a a GI Joe
figurine it's the strangest thing on
earth and then he walks away with 50
billion dollars he did great and yeah
obviously they loved him the Congress
loved him do you think it was more do
you think he wanted to come over here or
do you think the Biden Administration
wanted him over here for you know for
political purposes I think it's a little
bit of both uh it's you know he comes
over here and says hey thanks for thanks
for what you've done for us but we need
more money and oh by the way it's not
chair charity but without a doubt uh and
and you know this election sort of uh
didn't go exactly as a lot of people
thought it would but there's an enormous
amount of pen up frustration towards
this Administration and uh with the
economy and uh so without a doubt I mean
you know some uh you know he he
definitely helps the Biden
Administration yeah uh Molly do you get
tired of Biden taking credit for all the
jobs he's created which were really just
people getting fired during covet it's
amazing you know we had two quarters of
negative growth this year everyone knows
that means that you're in a recession
they redefine it so that we can say
we're not in a recession and then they
come out with these job numbers right
before the election saying that there
were these miraculous like a million
jobs oh it was actually ten thousand
it's really just amazing what he can get
away with yeah I mean the the fact that
they always have to kind of look on the
sunny side you can't blame them for that
but when they're really fudging numbers
that's what gets me me Julie yeah uh so
you know would you say this would you
classify this as a bad week for the
Bible oh it's a bad week all right but
you know what you know this this just
further backs up my long-standing
analogy
um that has stood the test of time for
centuries Size Matters
and when you're that old yes and and you
haven't been told this by the past girls
I've never heard such a thing Julie oh
okay so when you embellish the truth or
size of something or it it's good you're
gonna get caught you know what I mean
and it's just another sad and desperate
measure by the Biden administration
because they were caught I mean a
million it was uh what was it one
million 47
000 jobs when the number was really ten
thousand five hundred I mean you can't
put lipstick on a pig and when you you
know at the end of the day it's it's a
pig do you really think there's friction
with uh Biden and Kamala
I mean he wants to tuck her away and and
put her out to pasture but it's too late
he he he added her to his ticket I mean
why do you think she doesn't go anywhere
she was supposed to take care of the
Border she's never gone there the
president has never been there in his
whole damn life um and she hasn't done
anything so uh yeah she's a work in
progress all right but there is no
progress she's just a piece of work you
know what
Joe do you agree that Kamala is a work
in progress that's a phrase that Joe's
you used I think when he said that he
probably means that he hasn't sniffed
her hair yet
but to me the insane part of this is
that Joe Biden lies so much that his
house got struck by lightning and
started a fire and then he lied about
the fire
I mean you're the president we're
impressed you don't have to
embellishing fire I know he's got he's
so old he has plenty of stories why is
he always he first of all he uses the
same ones he's talking about Corn Pop
and he's making up other stories about
the purple heart but I mean he's lit
he's led a long life you think you could
find some real stories to tell yeah the
the Amtrak story it's not really that
action-packed I'd like to hear more
about the time that you were president
[Laughter]
but a great column this week about the
uh about McConnell in the Senate and uh
you know I think something about this
Administration
if you compare them on a scale people
aren't that happy with Congress or
either are they it's amazing you've got
the vast majority of the country upset
about the direction that the country is
going in you had an election where you
had the Republicans take over the house
and Mitch McConnell led a bunch of
Republicans to help the Biden
Administration with a 1.7 trillion
dollar Omnibus like this cheerleading
for it and was very happy with the
results that's right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else